[Music]
welcome to the reason Round Table your
very own libertarian fighter plane
shooting down the balloon of statism
I'm Matt Welch joined by nicolesby
Catherine mangy Warden special guest
star Elizabeth Nolan Brown please clap
howdy hey Matt hi
uh it seems like you cannot open up a
browser tab these days in my case period
but uh for people who are more agile uh
without running into Florida Governor uh
Ron DeSantis opening up a new front in
his ongoing administrative culture war
against what you might call and he
probably does call the woke state
at a press conference last week DeSantis
unveiled a package to go after what he
called academic discrimination and
indoctrination
in the sunshine State's higher education
system including dismantling various
diversity equity and inclusion programs
that's Dei for short and letting College
presidents and Boards hire who they want
to instead of deferring to faculty which
would be kind of a major shift he was he
has rejected a pilot uh advanced
placement high school course in
African-American studies he's installed
uh anti-woke activists like Chris Ruffo
in key oversight positions and it's not
just school he's going after the liquor
licenses of establishments that hold
drag shows viewable by kids allegedly
um also the business licenses of
companies that don't use the federal
e-verified database for confirming the
immigration legality of employees
and this week he's repeatedly reportedly
and probably both reconsidering opening
up those libel laws to make it easier to
sue big media it's kind of a lot what's
going on uh and of course it comes
against the backdrop of him presumably
he presumably uh running for the
president in 2024 Catherine
um these moves it seems like I've opened
up a bit of a split
between uh some conservatives who are
applauding him fighting and a lot more
classical liberal types who may have
joined the conservatives in the
underlying critique of the woke capture
of Institutions but don't like what he's
doing what say you from a kind of high
level
generalized approach of desantism versus
the wokisms I mean is doing what this
new generation of Republicans said they
were gonna do what
um the kind of tradcon napcon whatever
you want to call them guys told them to
do which is abandon the pretense that we
can achieve the ends that we want by
letting people be free and make their
own choices and instead are just using
the power of the state to get what they
want everywhere and always uh Matt you
did miss one important thing that
DeSantis did last week which was to make
gas stoves tax-free
that's right so just just keep that in
mind as well
um no more woke stoves no more woke
stoves no more woke
electricity is the enemy mat yep I mean
they're putting it in the cars Nick and
in the stoves
weather balloon all electric I mean no I
mean I I am I am troubled by this trend
because it's what I think the
interpretation will be is that this is
working that you know DeSantis is
raising his profile every single week he
is putting himself in a better position
to potentially win the presidency
and he is doing it through
indiscriminate use of state power not
only to achieve kind of broader ends but
also just to score points I mean the gas
stoves thing is a great example like the
it turned out that the kerfuffle about
the potential Banning of gas stoves
wasn't real it's not happening and it
doesn't matter DeSantis still said I'm
just gonna I'm just gonna get myself a
headline on this that is not a good way
to run a state and is not a good way to
run a country at the same time uh
Florida budget looks kind of good and
um
you know he is
he is doing stuff that I like in between
the stuff that I hate and I can see how
Republicans who are not already deeply
committed to libertarian principles will
say
rounded up to good enough let's vote for
this guy to be clear there is some uh
local skirmishes in the gas stove Wars
that are real I think in Manhattan new
construction of Apartments can't have
them in that but this was in direct
response to what turned out to be
essentially a misunderstanding
in the last couple I think he should
ship gas stoves to uh Martha's Vineyard
that is what we're talking about you're
using covid funds I think it would be
ideal uh Nick I I know that you have
some skepticism about the underlying
kind of assumption
um that they're based this on that the
institutions have been captured higher
education particular but other ones by
uh by a sort of dominant uh woke explain
that maybe against the backdrop of of
what we have seen or read from people
like Jonathan height over the years
which is you know he'll go in front of a
bunch of social psychologists or whoever
and say raise your hand if you're
conservative and there's just nobody I
mean it's just it's a shutout
um so uh what's what's your sense of the
underlying kind of felt need by
conservatives and desantisists to uh to
fight back yeah what uh what I mean by
that is not that
um faculty and universities aren't
overwhelmingly not just liberal but
left-wing and I think it's important to
you know maintain a serious distinction
between people who are far left and
people who are kind of Centrist liberals
um and I I remember back in my grad
school days in the early 90s when you
know it was the commies in the hallways
of the uh of the Sunni Buffalo English
Department who were ranting about how
Bill Clinton you know was a conservative
Etc you know and they and they have a
point Bill Clinton was not a progressive
leftist Etc but in any case you know the
professoriat is one thing but the effect
on children or on students is something
very different and I think there's often
a confusion uh there
um because you know like throughout
throughout the 80s and 90s as the left
made along March through the
institutions you know Republicans kept
getting elected president for the most
part and taking over Congress and things
like that and I think what what bothers
me in the latest the Santa stuff and
Zach weisbiller has done great work on
uh both the laws about increasing
transparency for parents in Florida K-12
schools which I think is important you
know this is part of the don't say gay
uh law you know part of it which is I
think legitimate and under discussed uh
by many critics of DeSantis is the idea
that parents absolutely have a right to
more transparency about what's going on
in schools and things like that but when
you start talking about higher education
and like a stop woke act and things like
that I mean it leads to a absolute
diminution of academic not I don't even
want to say academic freedom just
intellectual seriousness uh where you
know professors can't talk about certain
things without being worried about other
things his attempt to kind of replace
the the trustees at new College which
was an experimental college or is an
experimental college in Florida and put
in people who don't even have advanced
degrees or any understanding of higher
education governance is pathetic and
it's so profoundly anti-intellectual I
think we should all be worried about
that the other large thing that I'll say
about DeSantis who I you know I'm not
opposed to in many ways and like what he
has done is he's stayed in the tradition
of Florida Governors including
Democratic Governors who basically keep
regulation low and taxes low and
services relatively low push towards
school choice and you know this is
something that Jeb Bush did it's even
something that Charlie Chris did and
Lawton Childs Etc like you know those
are good basic ideas that are really
important and I think what's going on
now is that in order to apply to the
base particularly to the trumpist base
DeSantis is pursuing a bunch of actions
which may work well to get the
Republican nomination but are going to
irradiate him and actual limited
government policies when it comes to
taxing and spending with a broad
population that is like yeah I want you
know I think the left is insane I don't
want to live in a world where we're
paying you know 40 50 60 percent taxes
everything is regulated to hell but I
also don't want to roll with a guy who
seems to have a an obsession about you
know grooming and about gayness and
about African-American history that is
just beyond what I can summon
Liz uh uh picking up on that you you
live in America's Heartland uh and in a
Republican state pretty much uh fully by
now
um is it your uh impression that uh that
you know opposition to drag time story
hour is just going to be a republican
litmus test uh for the foreseeable
future or is that like a kind of a a a
conservative Twitter bubble concern that
would draw blank stares from the modal
Republican voter in I don't know
Cincinnati Ohio I mean Ohio is not
it's not a super rabid cultural
conservatives or it doesn't seem to like
people around me don't seem as into some
of the the cultural War battles as you
might find in some southern states or or
other places
um I don't I don't I have not heard
anything about drag queen Story Hour
from from anyone around me and and it's
not I have heard um you know some people
my parents friends uh worried about
critical race Theory being taught in
schools and when you ask them to explain
it it is they just really kind of
stammer and have no idea or they just
say something like you know um a teacher
said after an act of police violence
like if anyone wants to talk to me about
like race or racial divisions and
policies or about my sexual orientation
um yeah ask ask me it's like a button
ask me about my sexual orientation but
um but no I have not I have not heard
any any freakouts about drag queens at
all in in Cincinnati um I don't know
maybe we're just buying the times maybe
they're coming soon
have you
that's true that's a couple uh a couple
of steps ahead but what do you take
about this sort of pugilistic approach
uh that we're seeing you know the but he
fights which they used to say about
Trump they're now saying about DeSantis
um uh what what is your uh uh feeling
about that kind of next step in
conservative yeah I think it's very
unfortunate um you know as even if you
don't like some of these things that he
is uh you know cracking down on or or
getting revenge on it's definitely one
of the classics sort of the The Cure is
worse than the disease kind of thing
where you know he's he's us you know
pretending to make a stand for freedom
of thought and all this stuff by being
super authoritarian and you can't you
can't accomplish Freedom through
authoritarian means
um it is interesting because I feel like
he is what happens when you focus
Trump's grievance politics like Trump
just got too distracted by his own like
weird Petty grievances which were
sometimes in line with the general uh
what people were mad about in
conservative spheres but also were
sometimes just like weird idiosyncratic
stuff that Trump was just obsessed with
so he couldn't really I think totally
capture I mean he was he was good at it
to a degree but then he'd get distracted
by weird things but DeSantis seems to
just be like very laser focused on what
is the cultural grievance that is going
to get me the most attraction at any
given moment in time and just sort of
laser honing in on that and and going
with it
Catherine I can hear a thousand
Federalist writers screaming uh as one
in agony it sounds beautiful
at our discussion to the to date is
there something uh necessarily wrong
with a uh politician in an executive
position just sort of looking at things
like preferential hiring practices
affirmative action positive
discrimination against Asians or
whatever the hell and saying hold on
this might be illegal and but also it's
immoral and I'm gonna to the extent that
I can put a stop to it I mean it's it
feels jarring because people haven't
really been talking about this stuff for
30 years maybe or maybe I'm wrong about
that
um but is there something like by
definition wrong with it isn't that uh
kind of
um a declaration of preference for a
more individualistic approach
I think that there's just a really
important distinction which is
everywhere and always I don't know maybe
I'm a broken record but there's some
stuff that DeSantis is in charge of
where he could remedy these problems
right so hey should he does he want to
get rid of preferential hiring in
government feel free my guy you are in
charge of Florida's HR like for the
government positions do you do that
um can he get rid of it for Josh Moe on
the corner absolutely not Josh Moe in
the corner is welcome to engage in
preferential hiring of whatever form he
likes and I just think like losing that
distinction sort of getting lost in the
like our Institute these these important
institutions they've gone wrong and I
can I alone can fix them that's not the
right approach like he he is he
absolutely and Biden I will say has done
this right the the coverage around the
protections for
um gain interracial marriages that um
that Biden made a big stink about really
did not emphasize the fact that it was
Federal recognition for federal
employees which he does have power over
and that is an appropriate use of his
power
and I think the trouble with the
scientists is that he is sort of fudging
those distinctions he's doing it on
purpose to kind of maximize his splashy
headlines his impact I generally do not
take the Federalist as my imagined
interlocutors but I will say like I've
been on Jonah Goldberg's podcast and he
and I have talked about this that he's
he is genuinely worried about the fact
that there are many many institutions
that he perceives that DeSantis
perceives to be in the thrall of the
left and the university is first among
them and that that actually is an
important problem that that is a real
and important problem for people who
think that uniform leftist ideology in
our Elites is not a good thing
um you know my answer is the I think
always true and always unsatisfying that
when the pendulum swings too far
alternate institutions will spring up or
people will lose faith in those
institutions and just turn away from
them I think we're seeing that there's
there is a you know there is a loss of
faith in our universities and that's
fine it's okay if we don't look to
universities to guide our culture
forever and ever amen there's plenty of
other ways that we can put together you
know highbrow culture in this country
and frankly on the scientific side like
on the stem side
universities seem to have completely
screwed the pooch like this is different
obviously than our fight about CRT or
whatever but
like all of science is broken like we
don't need to we don't need to
hyper focus on making sure that
universities are doing that work that
work is that work is not effective so I
guess I think
it's okay to turn away from an
institution and not know quite what's
going to come next the only answer isn't
always like a capture of the flag you
know King of the Hill we gotta have
control of the thing that currently has
power
that uh again I can hear people being
frustrated with that uh it echoes a a
common complaint that you hear from the
Chris ruffos of the world as he's like
criticizing Stephen Pinker for being
like insufficiently uh serious there's
ever a squish it's that Pinker he's just
uh but it's like okay Libertarians or
classical liberals or other people
what's your remedy
um is it to file a lawsuit that takes
five years to go through the court
system that's what so Amari says about
David French uh in in his uh critiques
um you know are we gonna wait for
Catherine's alternative institutions to
spring up 13 years from now
um is they're not a more robust uh
remedy and maybe a kind of a as as part
of that
um you know are we in a position now
where like the all the seemingly neutral
or impartial institutions uh in society
are just under too much stress from
polarization and and we can't think our
way out of it I I don't know how to
really respond to that with any
specificity but you know in terms of
K-12 education the solution to these
problems is robust school choice which
Florida is pushing on and things like
that and that is good but you can't have
school choice where you say let the
dollars follow the student and you know
what the parents want and then also
start saying you say you have school
choice but you can't teach whatever
we're going to dub CRT you can't have
schools where drag queens uh you know
apparently are the only faculty members
and they also staff all the teams you
know they're all the coaches and things
like that part of it is the the hysteria
that the right the cultural War hysteria
that the right is stoking and that the
left Stokes to some degree is is not as
universal or as you know terrifying drag
queens are not taking over all of
America's public libraries or private
libraries or public schools or anything
like that fix it through school choice
and allow people to find the play the
institutions that they want for their
kids on the K-12 level uh at at you know
the college level uh the fact of the
matter is is that you know there is
school choice in college and uh
Catherine is right there is a showering
on some level of of the romance of
college uh it really isn't showing up
yet in terms of the percentage of people
who decide to go on to college because
there is a wage premium but in places
like Florida uh and in places like Ohio
my older son graduated from Ohio State
uh one of the largest institutions in
the country and in many ways very
representative he said if he graduated
in 2016 he said if you wanted to hang
out exclusively with like left woke
people you could have if you wanted to
avoid it you could do that Etc there's a
lot more range out there than we're
giving credit for and the point is you
know if you believe in limited
government you should be empowering
individuals to access things on their
terms and I think to the extent that
DeSantis does that whether we're talking
about business or school or education or
whatever or theme parks uh it's all to
the good but to the extent that right
Wingers are trying to focus on these
culture War issues to the exclusion of
other things or you know more important
they're going to lose a lot of people
that they actually need to win things
like the presidency or a controlling you
know majority in Congress I mean let's
not forget the lesson of the midterm
elections was that when you in when you
nominate and run insane douchebags who
have a very tenuous grasp on reality and
are obsessed with drag queens and with
you know
non-existent election fraud that turns
elections and all of that kind of stuff
you lose the Republicans should be in a
place in Congress where they're
implementing an agenda that they might
have articulated but they didn't
articulate an agenda and they didn't
take up they didn't take power in
Congress like in a in a strong way
because they're obsessed with these
issues that have very little to do with
their you know supposed limited
government uh interests you lose except
in Ohio
um uh Liz uh the to put a cap on this
um part of the discussion one of the
critiques that you'll see conservatives
make about woke capitalism or whatever
um is that it wasn't just that you know
a constitutional uh recognition of gay
marriage took place it's that
um the winners were sore winners there's
a sort of a sense of forced tolerance
you have to wear if you're a a hockey
player a Russian hockey player on the
Philadelphia Flyers I know you follow
the NHL a lot you have to wear a gay
pride shirt like it's not enough just to
say okay you won and we're not going to
discriminate against you anymore it's
that you have to like make uh uh you
know pledges fealty or affiliation with
various groups and that is what's
provoking the backlash do you think
there's any validity to that critique
I mean I think there are definitely
people who want that to be who you know
people on the left who are who are
trying to do that but I think like Nick
said about so many you know different
institutions it's overblown this idea
that you have to is overblown
um there's a lot of people I think
conservatives who feel pressure just
because they want to be not questioned
at all and this isn't obviously this
isn't just a thing on the right you know
the left does this in their own way too
but I think you know there's a lot of
conservatives who want to not feel
uncomfortable at all about their beliefs
or want to not feel pressure at all they
want to be able to be in certain
institutions and not feel like they are
the minority or to you know they want to
feel cool and conservatism you know it
has never been cool and they want to be
you know the cool kids and it's not but
that doesn't mean you're being oppressed
you know I think people tend to confuse
those things
um I also just wanted to say I've been
doing some lectures at the University of
Cincinnati um talking to political
science and journalism students there
and this also gets to you know Nick's
point about about some of this being
overblown what we think of as as you
know this infection on campus of woke is
um
um we often take these stories about
Elite colleges or about you know
particular activist groups who are very
loud uh on certain colleges as
representative but I just don't think
they are and you know I was fully
prepared for the students that we that I
talked to at the University of
Cincinnati to be very
uh strident in their in their social
justice politics and not open to things
you know I haven't been on a college
campus in years I was like oh gosh are
they just going to be they're just gonna
be these horrible you know like we hear
about all the time and it it has not
been further from the truth like they've
been I mean I I think that there's
definitely a liberal bent among them
although there have been some
conservative students but but it has
been you know a sort of normal Centrist
Normie Centrist liberalism they've been
very open to different ideas they've
been very open to discussions and not
gotten uh mad at at me and my husband
also in soup saying he was way farther
to the left and um than I am when we
talk about our work and I've shared
reason work with them which you know
definitely challenges some of these
liberal ideas and and they've been very
receptive to it and not at all like this
you know these social justice monsters
that we often hear about
nice
um all right let's uh move on tomorrow
night President Joseph Robinette Biden
the second is uh set to deliver not only
the State of the Union Address but
reportedly some possible hints about
running for a second term in 2024 when
he will be a record-setting 1 000 years
old we tend to criticize Joe Biden on
this podcast a lot because he's the
president
um but in the a spirit of intellectual
flexibility of nothing else
Catherine let's each go around the table
and come up with the very best thing you
can say about the Biden presidency so
far we'll get to the bad stuff too but
Catherine do you want to start
um no come on you can do it why are you
so mean to me Matt
um uh uh so I I will say that
um
though I think he could have done more
um it is worth keeping in mind that
Biden has done some good work to restore
U.S immigration policy to a slightly
more sane position and
um you know I think we can agree that he
is screwed up at the Border in terms of
both messaging to people who are coming
in and putting Kamala Harris in charge
of it in the first place but um the fact
is that you know visas are back up
approaching pre-covered levels and
um he has made a sincere effort to
finalize the status of dreamers although
he has not been successful
um so I will just say now and always I
think that's like an important issue
that we don't talk about that much
because it's very very hard to make
progress on it and Biden has at the very
least returned us to a pre-trump status
quo more or less and I appreciate that
Liz can you say something nice about the
Joe Biden president maybe nicer than I
managed the Mind wasn't very good
of Afghanistan that's the thing that
immediately jumps to my mind that's
that's big for whatever else is
President you know he is that that is
something that other presidents before
him have refused to do it is something
that there was not a lot of political I
mean while there's a lot of popular will
to do there's not a lot of political
will to do
um it took some balls to just be like
I'm doing it I'm doing it I don't care
what everyone says this is the right
thing to do when I'm doing it and I
think that was admirable
uh it was my uh vote too yeah me too he
punched it really badly yeah
um uh so since we all agree on that one
thing let's go straight to the bats I
was gonna say he also is uh pretty he's
he's better on the drug war than his
predecessors uh which isn't you know
this is faint praise but it's something
particularly given the fact that he is
one of the architects of the drug war
and the penumbra of you know carceral
conditions and stuff that come out of
that so and he also murdered the balloon
someone had to do it yeah and he died
you know it wouldn't even have made it
across the Pacific Ocean map if Trump
had been in office so that is absolutely
true all right let's go to our sense of
what would be from your point of view
individually idiosyncratically uh the
worst thing about a second
Biden presidency Catherine he's gonna
lie about the economy again for four
years he's gonna lie over and over again
and lie it's it's it's really quite
infuriating so I read
um and you should always read the
excellent Glenn Kessler on
um presidential and political lies uh he
did a looking back at last year's State
of the Union which promises did he keep
which problems promises did he not keep
and uh he reminded me of Biden's plan
promise to cut energy costs for families
an average of 500 a year by combating
climate change and that number was from
nowhere about nothing like that was a
fully
made up number it's savings that were
supposed to take place eight years from
now which We're not gonna have anything
to do
with like current inflation and from a
report that said that the savings on
utility bills would be five dollars not
500. so what the hell man like we can't
just be out here lie and you know I have
a particular pet peeve on his like
weatherizing your house will save the
world thing it just for some reason has
always annoyed me
but to just throw that totally fake
number a four Pinocchio number according
to Glenn Kessler into his State of the
Union and bear no consequences for that
um and then of course his claim to Lo to
be uh in a position to lower the deficit
um that is as Kessler called it shell
game
um and uh Biden will not stop misleading
people about what he has done on that
front and I I don't know if I can take a
bunch more years of it Matt especially
with his tweets did you see them on
yesterday where he said he promised that
like uh that or that uh competition lack
of competition was costly in the average
household five thousand dollars a year
just like no no citation just like where
did that number come from
sure sure like five thousand that's just
competition for the government's
Monopoly man and it's costing me more
than five thousand dollars a year damn
it uh Liz what's your worst thing about
a second Biden tour I'll I'll stick in
the in the vein about the whole
competition thing I mean he's obsessed
with this idea of um you know big
businesses not not allowing enough
competition and he's really been
weaponizing the uh the Federal Trade
Commission and and put you know filling
it with people and filling his
administration with people who really
want to use Anti-Trust law in a new
weird way and you know not worry about
whether
um practices are harming consumers but
instead worry just about are they you
know making businesses too big and
they've just really been pushing a whole
lot of terrible antitrust policies and
they would really continue to do that
and just sort of stifle I mean even
everything from that like the
non-compete clauses there's just so much
where they're just trying to sort of uh
you know take more control of American
Business under this guise of fighting
Monopoly power
and they might actually make progress on
that I mean you know I think all you
know everything that he's going to say
in this state of the union obviously has
the big asterisk on it of Republican you
know uh Republican opposition but there
as Liz has written uh awesomely many
times there is a weird
trans partisan I guess coalition to
punish big businesses and I could I
could imagine a world in which Biden put
something together yeah maybe it's this
like NDA stuff or whatever that kind of
thing where he just like chips away at
the edges of
there's a business it exists I know its
name it is there for the enemy
Nick what's your uh worst nightmare
about uh uh Biden too uh Biden's second
term is spending
um you know because I mean he uh had a
tweet where uh or he didn't have a tweet
but it was somebody tweeted uh a moment
of him at a press conference saying he
has nothing to do with inflation uh that
you know and it's you know he's been in
office for two years has overseen spent
budgets you know in the first year
wasn't all him but it was a large part
uh due to him but two consecutive
budgets over six trillion dollars which
you know bumps us up almost 50 percent
from a couple of years ago it's like you
know that's part of the reason we have
inflation is that the government has
flooded the zone you know the treasury
with money uh you know there's the whole
fed thing going on and things like that
but it's just you know the spending is
out of control
um and I don't think that's going to
change
um and that is something that I think
Libertarians in particular need to
come up with if not new arguments new
ways of talking about this because we
have gone from a place where you know it
was common for the federal government to
spend 19 or 18 percent of uh GDP and now
we're comfortably residing well over 20
percent
um and you know and this is a ratchet
effect and like we have to figure out a
way to bring that down if we want to
actually have longer term
economic growth
um so to me it's it's really the
spending because you don't hear a lot of
republicans in Congress you do hear
people like Rand Paul and it's nice to
hear him you know doing this now about
spending
um the Republicans have shown that their
fair weather
um you know budget Hawks and things like
that but for me the second term of Biden
is is spending is is just going to stay
super hot
I'll add to that and synthesize with Liz
a little bit uh trade policy four more
years of Biden is four more years of the
Donald Trump trade policy more or less
and that's a bad policy um and it goes
against actually kind of uh expressed at
least in public opinion research uh
desires of the American public and it
just needlessly impoverishes us makes
everything more expensive including all
aspects of government when you make you
know have made in America Provisions to
whatever you know 10 feet of tunnel
um the federal government's going to pay
for digging under the Hudson River 10
years from now
um it's just nothing's going to get done
everything's more expensive it makes the
world a more fractious place it
impoverishes the poorest people it's bad
don't like it all right Matt also yeah
it's it's also the long shadow of if
Biden is president again and this is not
an argument for anybody else to be
president that I could think of but you
know it's winding down I mean he is
punching the clock he is you know
waiting for retirement and or death or
whatever and it's like you know we we
need a we needed a reset before
[Music]
welcome to the reason Round Table your
very own libertarian fighter plane
shooting down the balloon of statism
I'm Matt Welch joined by Nicole Espy
Catherine mangy Warden special guest
star Elizabeth Nolan Brown please clap
howdy hey Matt hi
uh it seems like you cannot open up a
browser tab these days in my case period
but uh for people who are more agile uh
without running into Florida Governor uh
Ron DeSantis opening up a new front in
his ongoing administrative culture war
against what you might call him and he
probably does call the woke state at a
press conference last week DeSantis
unveiled the package to go after what he
called academic discrimination and
indoctrination
in the sunshine State's higher education
system including dismantling various
diversity equity and inclusion programs
that's Dei for short and letting College
presidents and Boards hire who they want
to instead of deferring to faculty which
would be kind of a major shift he was he
has rejected a pilot uh advanced
placement high school course in
African-American studies he's installed
uh anti-woke activist like Chris Ruffo
in key oversight positions and it's not
just school he's going after the liquor
licenses of establishments that hold
drag shows viewable by kids allegedly
um also the business licenses of
companies that don't use the federal
e-verified database for confirming the
immigration legality of employees
and this week he's repeatedly reportedly
and probably both reconsidering opening
up those libel laws to make it easier to
sue big media it's kind of a lot what's
going on uh and of course it comes
against the backdrop of him presumably
he presumably uh running for the
president in 2024 Catherine
um these moves it seems like I've opened
up a bit of a split
between uh some conservatives who are
applauding him fighting and a lot more
classical liberal types who may have
joined the conservatives in the
underlying critique of the woke capture
of Institutions but don't like what he's
doing what say you from a kind of high
level
generalized approach of desantism versus
the wokisms in is doing what this new
generation of Republicans said they were
gonna do what
um the kind of tradcon napcon whatever
you want to call them guys told them to
do which is abandon the pretense that we
can achieve the ends that we want by
letting people be free and make their
own choices and instead are just using
the power of the state to get what they
want everywhere and always uh Matt you
did miss one important thing that
DeSantis did last week which was to make
gas stoves tax-free
that's right so just just keep that in
mind as well
um no more woke stoves no more woke
stoves no more woke
electricity is the enemy mat yep I mean
they're putting it in the cars Nick and
in the stoves
weather balloon all electric I mean no I
mean I I am I am troubled by this trend
because it's what I think the
interpretation will be is that this is
working that you know DeSantis is
raising his profile every single week he
is putting himself in a better position
to potentially win the presidency
and he is doing it through
indiscriminate use of state power not
only to achieve kind of broader ends but
also just to score points I mean the gas
stoves thing is a great example like the
it turned out that the kerfuffle about
the potential Banning of gas stoves
wasn't real it's not happening and it
doesn't matter DeSantis still said I'm
just gonna I'm just gonna get myself a
headline on this that is not a good way
to run a state and is not a good way to
run a country at the same time uh
Florida budget looks kind of good and
um
you know he is
he is doing stuff that I like in between
the stuff that I hate and I can see how
Republicans who are not already deeply
committed to libertarian principles will
say
rounded up to good enough let's vote for
this guy to be clear there is some uh
local skirmishes in the gas stove Wars
that are real I think in Manhattan new
construction of Apartments can't have
them in that but this was in direct
response to what turned out to be
essentially a misunderstanding
in the last couple I think he should
ship gas stoves to uh Martha's Vineyard
that is what we're talking about you're
using covid funds I think it would be
ideal uh Nick I I know that you have
some skepticism about the underlying
kind of assumption
um that they're based this on that the
institutions have been captured higher
education in particular but other ones
by uh by a sort of dominant uh woke
explain that maybe against the backdrop
of of what we have seen or read from
people like Jonathan height over the
years which is you know he'll go in
front of a bunch of social psychologists
or whoever and say raise your hand if
you're conservative and there's just
nobody I mean it's just it's a shutout
um so uh what's what's your sense of the
underlying kind of felt need by
conservatives and desantisists to uh to
fight back yeah what uh what I mean by
that is not that
um faculty and universities aren't
overwhelmingly not just liberal but
left-wing and I think it's important to
you know maintain a serious distinction
between people who are far left and
people who are kind of Centrist liberals
um and I I remember back in my grad
school days in the early 90s when you
know it was the commies in the hallways
of the uh of the Sunni Buffalo English
Department who were ranting about how
Bill Clinton you know was a conservative
Etc you know and they and they have a
point Bill Clinton was not a progressive
leftist et cetera but in any case you
know the professoriat is one thing but
the effect on children or on students is
something very different and I think
there's often a confusion uh there
um because you know like throughout
throughout the 80s and 90s as the left
made along March through the
institutions you know Republicans kept
getting elected president for the most
part and taking over Congress and things
like that and I think what what bothers
me in the latest the Santa stuff and
Zach weisbiller has done great work on
uh both the laws about increasing
transparency for parents in Florida K-12
schools which I think is important you
know this is part of the don't say gay
uh law you know part of it which is I
think legitimate and under discussed uh
by many critics of DeSantis is the idea
that parents absolutely have a right to
more transparency about what's going on
in schools and things like that but when
you start talking about higher education
and like a stop woke act and things like
that I mean it leads to a absolute
diminution of academic not I don't even
want to say academic freedom just
intellectual seriousness uh where you
know professors can't talk about certain
things without being worried about other
things his attempt to kind of replace
the the trustees at new College which
was an experimental college or is an
experimental college in Florida and put
in people who don't even have advanced
degrees or any understanding of higher
education governance is pathetic and
it's so profoundly anti-intellectual I
think we should all be worried about
that the other large thing that I'll say
about DeSantis who I you know I'm not
opposed to in many ways and like what he
has done is he's stayed in the tradition
of Florida Governors including
Democratic Governors who basically keep
regulation low and taxes low and
services relatively low push towards
school choice and you know this is
something that Jeb Bush did it's even
something that Charlie Chris did and
Lawton Childs
Etc like you know those are good basic
ideas that are really important and I
think what's going on now is that in
order to apply to the base particularly
to the trumpist base DeSantis is
pursuing a bunch of actions which may
work well to get the Republican
nomination but are going to irradiate
him and actual limited government
policies when it comes to taxing and
spending with a broad population that is
like yeah I want you know I think the
left is insane I don't want to live in a
world where we're paying you know 40 50
60 percent taxes everything is regulated
to hell but I also don't want to roll
with a guy who seems to have a an
obsession about you know grooming and
about gayness and about African-American
history that is just beyond what I can
summon
Liz uh uh picking up on that you you
live in America's Heartland uh and in a
Republican state pretty much uh fully by
now
um is it your uh impression that uh that
you know opposition to drag time story
hour is just going to be a republican
litmus test uh for the foreseeable
future or is that like a kind of a a a
conservative Twitter bubble concern that
would draw blank stares from the modal
Republican voter in I don't know
Cincinnati Ohio uh I mean Ohio is not
it's not a super rabid cultural
conservatives or it doesn't seem to like
people around me don't seem as into some
of the the cultural War battles as you
might find in some southern states or or
other places
um I don't I don't I have not heard
anything about drag queen Story Hour
from from anyone around me and and it's
not I have heard
um you know some people my parents
friends uh worried about critical race
Theory being taught in schools and when
you ask them to explain it it is they
just really kind of stammer and have no
idea or they just say something like you
know um a teacher said after an act of
police violence like if anyone wants to
talk to me about like race or racial
divisions and policies or about my
sexual orientation I'm okay yeah ask ask
me it's like a button ask me about my
sexual orientation but um but no I have
not I have not heard any any freakouts
about drag queens at all in in
Cincinnati um I don't know maybe we're
just buying the times maybe they're
coming soon
yet
that's true that's a couple uh a couple
of steps ahead but what do you take
about this sort of pugilistic approach
uh that we're seeing you know the but he
fights which they used to say about
Trump they're now saying about DeSantis
um uh what what is your uh uh feeling
about that kind of next step in
conservative yeah I think it's very
unfortunate um you know as even if you
don't like some of these things that he
is uh you know cracking down on or or
getting revenge on it's definitely one
of the classic sort of the The Cure is
worse than the disease kind of thing
where you know he's he's us you know
pretending to make a stand for freedom
of thought and all this stuff by being
super authoritarian and you can't you
can't accomplish Freedom through
authoritarian means
um it is interesting because I feel like
he is what happens when you focus
Trump's grievance politics like Trump
just got too distracted by his own like
weird Petty grievances which were
sometimes in line with the general uh
what people were mad about in
conservative spheres but also were
sometimes just like weird idiosyncratic
stuff that Trump was just obsessed with
so he couldn't really I think totally
capture I mean he was he was good at it
to a degree but then he'd get distracted
by weird things but DeSantis seems to
just be like very laser focused on what
is the cultural grievance that is going
to get me the most traction at any given
moment in time and just sort of laser
honing in on that and and going with it
Catherine I can hear a thousand
Federalist writers screaming uh as one
in agony it sounds beautiful
at our discussion to the to date is
there something uh necessarily wrong
with a uh politician in an executive
position just sort of looking at things
like preferential hiring practices
affirmative action positive
discrimination against Asians or
whatever the hell and saying hold on
this might be illegal and but also it's
immoral and I'm gonna to the extent that
I can put a stop to it I mean it's it
feels jarring because people haven't
really been talking about this stuff for
30 years maybe or maybe I'm wrong about
that
um but is there something like by
definition wrong with it isn't that uh
kind of
um a declaration of preference for a
more individualistic approach
I think that there's just a really
important distinction which is
everywhere and always I don't know maybe
I'm a broken record but there's some
stuff that DeSantis is in charge of
where he could remedy these problems
right so hey should he do does he want
to get rid of preferential hiring in
government feel free my guy you are in
charge of Florida's HR like for the
government positions do you do that
um can he get rid of it for Josh Moe on
the corner absolutely not Josh Moe in
the corner is welcome to engage in
preferential hiring of whatever form he
likes and I just think like losing that
distinction sort of getting lost in the
like our Institute these these important
institutions they've gone wrong and I
can I alone can fix them that's not the
right approach like he he is he
absolutely and Biden I will say has done
this right the the coverage around the
protections for
um gay and interracial marriages that um
that Biden made a big stink about really
did not emphasize the fact that it was
Federal recognition for federal
employees which he does have power over
and that is an appropriate use of his
power
and I think the trouble with the
scientists is that he is sort of fudging
those distinctions he is doing it on
purpose to kind of maximize his splashy
headlines his impact I generally do not
take the Federalist as my imagined
interlocutors but I will say like I've
been on Jonah Goldberg's podcast and he
and I have talked about this that he's
he is genuinely worried about the fact
that there are many many institutions
that he perceives that DeSantis
perceives to be in the thrall of the
left and the university is first among
them and that that actually is an
important problem that that is a real
and important problem for people who
think that uniform leftist ideology in
our Elites is not a good thing
um you know my answer is the I think
always true and always unsatisfying that
when the pendulum swings too far
alternate institutions will spring up or
people will lose faith in those
institutions and just turn away from
them I think we're seeing that there's
there is a you know there is a loss of
faith in our universities and that's
fine it's okay if we don't look to
universities to guide our culture
forever and ever amen there's plenty of
other ways that we can put together you
know highbrow culture in this country
and frankly on the scientific side like
on the stem side
universities seem to have completely
screwed the pooch like this is different
obviously than our fight about CRT or
whatever but like all of science is
broken like we don't need to we don't
need to
hyper focus on making sure that
universities are doing that work that
work is that work is not effective so I
guess I think it's okay to turn away
from an institution and not know quite
what's going to come next the only
answer isn't always like a capture of
the flag you know King of the Hill we
gotta have control of the thing that
currently has power
that uh again I can hear people being
frustrated with that uh it echoes a a
common complaint that you hear from the
Chris ruffos of the world as he's like
criticizing Stephen Pinker for being
like insufficiently uh serious there's
ever a squish it's that Pinker he's just
uh but it's like okay Libertarians or
classical liberals or other people
what's your remedy
um is it to file a lawsuit that takes
five years to go through the court
system that's what so Amari says about
David French uh in in his uh critiques
um you know are we gonna wait for
Catherine's alternative institutions to
spring up 13 years from now
um is they're not a more robust uh
remedy and maybe a kind of a as as part
of that
um you know are we in a position now
where like the all the seemingly neutral
or impartial institutions uh in society
are just under too much stress from
polarization and and we can't think our
way out of it I I don't know how to
really respond to that with any
specificity but you know in terms of
K-12 education the solution to these
problems is robust school choice which
Florida is pushing on and things like
that and that is good but you can't have
school choice where you say let the
dollars follow the student and you know
what the parents want and then also
start saying you say you have school
choice but you can't teach whatever
we're going to dub CRT you can't have
schools where drag queens uh you know
apparently are the only faculty members
and they also staff all the teams you
know they're all the coaches and things
like that part of it is the the hysteria
that the right the cultural War hysteria
that the right is stoking and that the
left Stokes to some degree is is not as
universal or as you know terrifying drag
queens are not taking over all of
America's public libraries or private
libraries or public schools or anything
like that fix it through school choice
and allow people to find the play the
institutions that they want for their
kids on the K-12 level uh at at you know
the college level uh the fact of the
matter is is that you know there is
school choice in college and uh
Catherine is right there is a showering
on some level of of the romance of
college uh it really isn't showing up
yet in terms of the percentage of people
who decide to go on to college because
there is a wage premium but in places
like Florida uh and in places like Ohio
my older son graduated from Ohio State
uh one of the largest institutions in
the country and in many ways very
representative he said if he graduated
in 2016 he said if you wanted to hang
out exclusively with like left woke
people you could have if you wanted to
avoid it you could do that Etc there's a
lot more range out there than we're
giving credit for and the point is you
know if you believe in limited
government you should be empowering
individuals to access things on their
terms and I think to the extent that
DeSantis does that whether we're talking
about business or school or education or
whatever or theme parks uh it's all to
the good but to the extent that right
Wingers are trying to focus on these
culture War issues to the exclusion of
other things or you know more important
they're going to lose a lot of people
that they actually need to win things
like the presidency or a controlling you
know majority in Congress I mean let's
not forget the lesson of the midterm
elections was that when you in when you
nominate and run insane douchebags who
have a very tenuous grasp on reality and
are obsessed with drag queens and with
you know
non-existent election fraud that turns
elections and all of that kind of stuff
you lose the Republicans should be in a
place in Congress where they're
implementing an agenda that they might
have articulated but they didn't
articulate an agenda and they didn't
take they didn't take power in Congress
like in a in a strong way because
they're obsessed with these issues that
have very little to do with their you
know supposed limited government uh
interests you lose except in Ohio
um uh Liz uh the to put a cap on this
um part of the discussion one of the
critiques that you'll see conservatives
make about capitalism or whatever
um is that it wasn't just that you know
a constitutional uh recognition of gay
marriage took place it's that
um the winners were sore winners there's
a sort of a sense of forced tolerance
you have to wear if you're a a hockey
player a Russian hockey player on the
Philadelphia Flyers I know you follow
the NHL a lot you have to wear a gay
pride shirt like it's not enough just to
say okay you won and we're not going to
discriminate against you anymore it's
that you have to like make uh uh you
know pledges fealty or affiliation with
various groups and that is what's
provoking the backlash do you think
there's any validity to that critique
I mean I think there are definitely
people who who want that to be who you
know people on the left who are who are
trying to do that but I think like Nick
said about so many you know different
institutions it's it's overblown this
idea that you have to is overblown
um there's a lot of people I think
conservatives who feel pressure just
because they want to be not questioned
at all and this isn't obviously this
isn't just a thing on the right you know
the left does this in their own way too
but I think you know there's a lot of
concerns who want to not feel
uncomfortable at all about their beliefs
or want to not feel pressure at all they
want to be able to be in certain
institutions and not feel like they are
the minority or to you know they want to
feel cool and conservatism you know it
has never been cool when they want to be
you know the cool kids and it's not but
that doesn't mean you're being oppressed
you know I think people tend to confuse
those things
um I also just wanted to say I've been
doing some lectures at the University of
Cincinnati um talking to political
science and journalism students there
and this also gets to you know Nick's
point about about some of this being
overblown what we think of as as you
know this infection on campus of woke is
um
um we often take these stories about
Elite colleges or about you know
particular activist groups who are very
loud uh on certain colleges as
representative but I just don't think
they are and you know I was fully
prepared for the students that we that I
talked to at the University of
Cincinnati to be very
as strident in their in their social
justice politics and not open to things
you know I haven't been on a college
campus in years I was like oh gosh are
they just going to be they're just gonna
be these horrible you know like we hear
about all the time and it it has not
been further from the truth like they've
been I mean I I think that there's
definitely a liberal bent among them
although there have been some
conservative students but but it has
been you know a sort of normal Centrist
Normie Centrist liberalism they've been
very open to different ideas they've
been very open to discussions and not
gotten uh mad at at me and my husband
also in soup saying he was way farther
to the left and um than I am when we
talk about our work and I've shared
reason work with them which you know
definitely challenges some of these
liberal ideas and and they've been very
receptive to it and not at all like this
you know these social justice monsters
that we often hear about
nice
um all right let's uh move on tomorrow
night President Joseph Robinette Biden
the second is uh set to deliver not only
the State of the Union Address but
reportedly some possible hints about
running for a second term in 2024 when
he will be a record-setting 1 000 years
old we tend to criticize Joe Biden on
this podcast a lot because he's the
president
um but in the spirit of intellectual
flexibility of nothing else
Catherine let's each go around the table
and come up with the very best thing you
can say about the Biden presidency so
far we'll get to the bad stuff too but
Catherine do you want to start
um no come on you can do it why are you
so mean to me Matt
um uh so I I will say that
um
though I think he could have done more
um it is worth keeping in mind that
Biden has done some good work to restore
U.S immigration policy to a slightly
more sane position and
um you know I think we can agree that he
is screwed up at the Border in terms of
both messaging to people who are coming
in and putting Kamala Harris in charge
of it in the first place but the fact is
that you know visas are back up
approaching pre-covered levels and
um he has made a sincere effort to
finalize the status of dreamers although
he has not been successful
um so I will just say now and always I
think that's like an important issue
that we don't talk about that much
because it's very very hard to make
progress on it and Biden has at the very
least returned us to a pre-trump status
quo more or less and I appreciate that
Liz can you say something nice about the
Joe Biden president maybe nicer than I
managed the Mind wasn't very good
Afghanistan that's the thing that
immediately jumps to my mind that's
that's big for whatever else is
President you know he is that that is
something that other presidents before
him have refused to do it is something
that there was not a lot of political I
mean while there's a lot of popular will
to do there's not a lot of political
will to do
um it took some balls to just be like
I'm doing it I'm doing it I don't care
what everyone says this is the right
thing to do when I'm doing it and I
think that was admirable
uh it was my uh vote too yeah he punched
it really badly yeah
um uh so since we all agree on that one
thing let's go straight to the bats I
was gonna say he also is uh pretty he's
he's better on the drug war than his
predecessors uh which isn't you know
this is faint praise but it's something
particularly given the fact that he is
one of the architects of the drug war
and the penumbra of you know carceral
conditions and stuff that come out of
that so and he also murdered the balloon
someone had to do it yeah and he died he
murdered that balloon you know it
wouldn't even have made it across the
Pacific Ocean map if Trump had been in
office so that is absolutely true all
right let's go to our sense of what
would be from your point of view
individually idiosyncratically uh the
worst thing about a second
Biden presidency Catherine he's gonna
lie about the economy again for four
years he's gonna lie over and over again
and lie it's it's it's really quite
infuriating so I read
um and you should always read the
excellent Glenn Kessler on
um presidential and political lies uh he
did a looking back at last year's State
of the Union which promises did he keep
which problems promises did he not keep
and uh he reminded me of Biden's plan
promise to cut energy costs for families
an average of 500 a year by combating
climate change and that number was from
nowhere about nothing like that was a
fully
made up number it's savings that were
supposed to take place eight years from
now which We're not gonna have anything
to do
with like current inflation and from a
report that said that the savings on
utility bills would be five dollars not
500. so what the hell man like we can't
just be out here lie and you know I have
a particular pet peeve on his like
weatherizing your house will save the
world thing it just for some reason has
always annoyed me but to just throw that
totally fake number a four Pinocchio
number according to Glenn Kessler into
his State of the Union and bear no
consequences for that
um and then of course his claim to look
to be uh in a position to lower the
deficit
um that is as Kessler called it shell
game
um and uh Biden will not stop misleading
people about what he has done on that
front and I I don't know if I can take a
bunch more years of it Matt especially
with his tweets did you see the one
yesterday where he said he promised that
like that or that uh competition lack of
competition was costing the average
household five thousand dollars a year
just like no no citation just like where
did that number come from
sure sure like five thousand that's just
competition for the government's
Monopoly man and it's costing me more
than five thousand dollars a year damn
it uh Liz what's your worst thing about
a second Biden tour uh I'll I'll stick
in the in the vein of the whole
competition thing I mean he's obsessed
with this idea of um you know big
businesses not not allowing enough
competition and he's really been
weaponizing the uh the Federal Trade
Commission and and put you know filling
it with people and filling his
administration with people who really
want to use Anti-Trust law in a new
weird way and you know not worry about
whether
um practices are harming consumers but
instead worry just about are they you
know making businesses too big and
they've just really been pushing a whole
lot of terrible antitrust policies and
they would really continue to do that
and just sort of stifle I mean even
everything from that like the
non-compete clauses there's just so much
where they're just trying to sort of uh
you know take more control of American
Business under this guise of fighting
Monopoly power
and they might actually make progress on
that I mean you know I think all you
know everything that he's going to say
in this state of the union obviously has
the big asterisk on it of Republican you
know uh Republican opposition but there
as Liz has written uh awesomely many
times there is a weird
trans partisan I guess coalition to
punish big businesses and I could I
could imagine a world in which Biden put
something together yeah maybe it's this
like NDA stuff or whatever that kind of
thing where he just like chips away at
the edges of
there's a business it exists I know its
name it is there for the enemy
Nick what's your uh worst nightmare
about uh uh Biden too uh Biden's second
term is spending